all right so you're on to bigger and
better things you split your time from
wyoming in california and now
you are full-time in wyoming i'm a
full-time cowgirl
i mean you i mean you're a native
californian so
yes it's a little shocking right it is
so what was it about wyoming you're like
i'm gonna just lay my roots and
foundations here now yeah
i think that in the last seven years
i've lived 10 lives i've had the
craziest
wildest career so far and i really was
seeking
peace and quiet yeah i really was i bet
and i've been here for 35 years i love
california so much obviously we're
standing in my building that's not going
anywhere
but i think for me i needed to wake up
in a different environment
finally yeah so to wake up with 4c all
different four
seasons and snow and there will be 50
deer just in my backyard chilling just
in the morning
i don't know that life i just i love it
and i really didn't think i would love
it
i'm so obsessed with it and so i mean
did you ever imagine that you would end
up in a place like that i mean i love
nature and things like that so kind of i
just never really kind of showed that
aspect
i'm very you know i'm very high fashion
mannequin
i think that underneath it all i really
like i love outdoor stuff i love camping
and i love just sitting
by the river and chilling and you're not
by the river in full glam
always in bulgaria okay that's like that
okay yeah spf foundation spf concealer
and an umbrella i have no words so tell
i want to know more about wyoming like
it's the dating scene out in wyoming
oh my god i think anyone from wyoming is
going to die right now
when they if when they're watching this
um it's a little bleak it is
yeah so we're the 10th biggest state and
there's only 565 000 people
in the entire state the entire state
okay that's chatsworth oh my god it is
like when you think of la with nine
million people
and then that whole entire state is like
a county of la it's wild
so to answer your question a lot of
people um stick with their high school
sweethearts i mean and that's it
okay and how does that make you feel i
mean are you looking i think it's
endearing yeah i think it's sweet yeah
um but i'm currently not looking okay
yeah okay yeah
and you never were on the apps or
anything were you never you know it's so
crazy i've never been on a dating app i
know i've known
ever okay yeah i'm sure there's people
posing as you on though
yeah oh yeah people have showed me that
before but i've never been on
um any app at all no grinder no what are
they all the other ones no tinder no
anything
bumble no none of it ever lucky
this isn't that wild never yeah but
you're happy now you're good
i really am no okay so we're single
love that for you okay see it's all
about summer of self-love it is
summer's love that's it for me i think i
was after my um
relationship ended we were five years in
love one of the best experiences of my
life
um i was kind of just hopping on and
dating random people and i really should
have worked on myself
so now we're on a full self reflection
and you know i like to die we'll have a
little fun in miami but
no more no more dating for me we have to
address something because i woke up
uh today and i was like
huh uh i guess allegedly jeffree star
has been sleeping with kanye west
um and that's why they're getting a
divorce
goodbye well speaking of relations we
have to talk about
the crazy kanye west rumors that you
guys were a thing
i'm still trying to wrap my head around
it i was very entertained i feel like
you got a kick out of it too though
i really did i think it was the i just
like the coincidences of
jeffrey and him live in hidden hills and
now we live in wyoming and it was just a
very weird time i think yeah i thought
it was hilarious i love rumors i think
they're funny but um
some girl on tik tok made it up and it
went viral before i even knew right
so i'm waking up in bed in wyoming like
huh and i didn't even see the you know
we all have our daily routines i wake up
i
my new thing is for the last year and a
half i don't wake up and immediately
grab my phone
i think that's a very uh a behavior that
i had to stop
i wake up i enjoy the weather i take my
dogs out i do a little exercise and then
i hop on
so i so i didn't even get to go to
twitter or instagram i just saw my mom
going what the hell is this
and i'm like what the hell is what mom
had some questions she did
she's like are you not telling me
something and i'm like what are you
talking about and then i click it and i
was like oh
got it so it was hilarious
[Applause]
[Music]
we know kanye is in wyoming do you ever
see him i imagine wyoming's so small and
i don't mean to do that no no no no but
it's the tenth biggest date so we're
really far apart you're far apart oh
yeah
okay yeah everything happened no no no
i'm uh in casper and he's in cody so
that's like six
six hours yeah yeah i'm just waiting for
him to get you like to collab with him
or you collect like he collabs with you
listen we don't have to collab sexually
but if we want to collect with
yeezys call you know my address exactly
so you guys have no
relationship no as far as yeah okay i
know it sounds fun but i prefer
uh taller wrappers and that's that
that's on that
it's the height for me okay
yeah i just want to turn on the camera
and
just talk and vent and let you guys know
what's been happening there's been
so many things i haven't been ready to
talk about
but i do want to let everyone know that
for the first time
in my life at 35 years old i am
finally leaving california so um
what are the biggest changes that you're
hoping to see you know in yourself
okay by making this big move to wyoming
and also just by growing your empire
yeah i think the main thing is
continuing on
inner peace real happiness um
and la was just giving me something
that i was kind of over yeah i've been
here for so long so
i think wyoming brings me so much uh it
brings me joy
and it really reset me because you see
all this madness behind you
everything all came from here yeah so i
was going through like a creative rut
and i actually have never told anyone
that before last year i went through a
little creative slump for the first time
in seven years
wow and i was like whoa this is crazy
and there was just so much
uh there was just so much happening i
think that i just my brain just kind of
went
what's next which i'm sure sh probably
scared you a little bit
because what are you without your
creativity exactly yeah so after like a
month of
fully being out there because i kept
doing trips like a week here a week
there and then i'm like no i need to be
out there for a few months
yeah and that re-sparked everything and
i got to just reset my brain and then we
we've already created everything up
until 2023 so i'm on the street right
now i'm on youtube
i'm on a creative street i love it so
there's no time for bs then huh there
isn't
you're really focused yeah i love that i
know it may be hard to believe but i'm
really focused oh no looking around my
own horn okay okay so in the youtube
video that you posted yesterday
you um alluded to unaddressed issues
that you had time to focus on so i'm
curious like what were some of the
biggest hurdles or
realizations that you came to oh i love
that okay um i think the main one for me
was i was always thinking with my
emotions quickly
when start when any situation would
happen with drama i just felt like i
for some reason had to prove myself and
immediately give the internet and my
audience
an answer instead of reflecting and
thinking about what was happening in the
moment i immediately grabbed my phone
yes said things and emotions said a lot
of things i didn't mean in the past
um and those are my biggest regrets yeah
so learning emotional control and
actually allowing myself to process
things instead of just
the internet needs an answer i'm going
to give it to them right now and i'm
like wait i haven't even thought about
what's happening
so a lot of self-reflection which has
been important how much
did the pandemic play a part in that
because i feel like that required all of
us to kind of slow down right
a lot yeah um the pandemic and my
accident i think were
the word blessings are not the right
word but they were
good for me they were good lessons they
were yeah there was a lot of down time a
lot of
time to really process everything and it
was a good
re-evaluation of what i wanted to do
next for sure and the kind of people you
want
around you and in your life you know so
my circle did switch up a lot and
get smaller yeah yeah absolutely well it
could happen for a lot of people oh for
sure you realize like who's really there
for you and
who's not